today's question comes from Jerry and
Connecticut my husband and I just
completed baby step 1 they've got their
thousand dollars will be starting baby
step 2 however he thinks it's ok to use
a credit card to pay bills each month so
we can get reward dollars back at the
end of the year I don't think it's a
good idea what do you think well I've
been on record for a long time Jerry
telling people to get rid of credit
cards and you know the funny thing about
this conversation is you guys are
sitting there broken in debt we're
giving you advice on how to get out of
debt and handle money and your husband
who's broken in debt has a better plan
that's just stupid I mean that's like
you're less like your 350 pounds and you
hire a personal trainer who's got
complete abs like an 8 pack 12 pack and
he says don't eat any more doughnuts and
you go yeah but my plan I use doughnuts
why'd you hire personal trainer
you're not going to get those abs with
those doughnuts it doesn't work I mean I
I know because I choose the doughnuts
often but you know what I'm saying I
mean if you're going to add if you're
going to get a proven plan and you're
bringing in an expert that has the proof
right in front of you submit yourself to
the plan don't change the plan and so
here's the thing about the reward points
with credit cards that's the biggest
scam on the planet you know how I know
because I've literally met with
thousands and thousands and thousands of
millionaires over 30 years of doing this
I have never met a single millionaire
and said Dave you know my financial
breakthrough those are my discover
points those airline miles Dave that's
what put me over the top man it changed
my life financially you know some of my
millions are there because I saved money
on a trip to Reno I mean give me a break
and you know you know what people do
they go buy crap that they don't need
with money that they don't have to
impress
people they don't really like so they
can get their airline miles up this is
what people do and credit card companies
count on that stuff so no cut up the
stupid credit card time to have plastic
surgery yeah but here's the thing don't
hire don't find someone who's an expert
in doing something and then question
everything they're doing just do it just
do it if they say you know drink water
out of a red cup only drink water out of
a red cup only I mean this is not its
Red Solo Cup time baby I mean that's it
that's your time not saying that's a
thing it's not a thing okay but whatever
it is even if it sounds absurd to you
your plan sucks you need a new plan if
you continue to do the same thing over
and over again and expect a different
result we call that the definition of
insanity hello if you keep making a cake
over and over and over again it turns
out chocolate you're wanting a vanilla
cake you probably ought to change the
recipe and don't ask Betty Crocker to
customize it to you that's stupid
open unclear hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]